i somewhat agree i
personally
it's very debatable because
sometimes sometimes women don't know
what they want and like you said like we
think sometimes we think we know what
they want by
like doing stuff like cooking and
cleaning and like spending more time
with them but like
it's like when the guy approaches them
first obviously
they think that they can look in it and
like oh let me try to be fair like oh
let me try this let me try that and it's
like
at the end we might not get what they
want and then we'll obviously get angry
because they are they approached us
first and it's just like what did you
well what did you want in the beginning
without any sex yeah of course
so it's just but like in this like
especially like i'm 24 as well like i'm
like if you like if you approach me and
like you really want no like you should
know what you like guys you should know
what you want as well like even sex yeah
yeah
yeah like
and then when when
when we don't want that you look i'm mad
do they get mad or do they move on no
some of them get mad
all right so what they're both yeah both
yeah fair enough uh so what i'd find
what i'd say is
male and female relationships are
transactional men want sex women want
relationships women control access to
sex
men control access to relationships
that's true it's a game that you're
playing with a guy
if you can withhold sex long enough for
him to kind of get to the point where he
feels like he needs to wife you
then you you're playing the game right
and but and also a lot of guys
if they know you've slept with guys
before like very quickly they're they're
they're and they want to date you but
you're making them wait they're just
thinking like what what am i doing here
you didn't make him wait
and so a lot of guys get frustrated and
just leave because you know it's like
you slept with three guys on the
football team so why on earth am i
waiting for this
i think guys would do the same but then
that just shows you wasn't serious in
the first place then that just shows
that he was just actually there for sex
because
no no tom got it quicker than harry no
it shows one men value purity so they
don't want a girl that slept with a lot
of guys that is fun for them but it's
fine for them to do
yeah because men and women are different
like it's easy for us you can walk
outside i could walk outside oh
i agree we're all human like it's not
like girls don't want to have sex
but it it's
valuable to a guy to have a girl that
hasn't had as many experiences because
it lowers your value the more people you
slept with i find that
men and women are different so
historically men had to ensure paternity
so they had to make sure that the woman
that they were sleeping with like that
she was passing on his genes
and so we can't make our biological like
need go away the same way we can't help
that we like men taller than us because
historically we had to find a guy to
protect us it's just innate in them they
can't help it
so it like
how ish
how would you feel if you were dating a
girl and you found out later like after
you were together that she slept with
three of your boys
three acquaintances you don't know them
well
that's still the same i found out later
yeah yeah i'd be human yeah yeah
yeah if i if i knew before
then i would have
i would have made a choice obviously i
wouldn't do it but i would have made a
choice to be there but if if i know
later on now i'm in deep then
i would be fuming because i've invested
all this time effort money to know that
there's brothers
in and around me looking at me going
yeah no i've now it kind of makes you
look yeah now what if what if you waited
a month to bang her and you found out
that all of them slept with her out on
the first date
yeah i'm fighting everyone
because a guy wants you to like view him
as the best that like you can do
so if if we're going around making one
guy wait and make giving it to another
guy immediately like to the guy
it's like you don't like him you liked
the other guys more and you're just
settling for the other guy right would
you man was that yeah yeah yeah that's a
good point because um men don't like to
feel like they're being settled for at
all what i think i think like um feeling
like a woman is there to settle for him
uh men like you said does like to feel
like um he is the best little
that woman wants kind of thing
um
[Music]
so the thing is i think
you know
whoever you you get as a partner
they want to be treated like a 10 and
you want to be treated like a 10.
whether you are objectively in terms of
beauty standards or not isn't the point
the kind of relationship you have with
your partner you should be
each other's ten yes you get what i'm
saying but
is that is that possible if uh
like a five is going for a ten
i don't think so i don't know
the problem is i don't think that can
happen where everyone gets their first
choice because
especially nowadays you have eighty
percent of women sleeping with twenty
percent of guys
so
the five thinks she's an eight because
she's sleeping with the eight nine or
ten and so
when she gets married she's gonna view
her husband as less that's another issue
with um sleeping with a lot of guys did
you know if you sleep with more than
five guys your chance of a happy
marriage after 10 years it goes from 80
percent to 25 percent
why why casual sex why because because
the more men you sleep with it you lose
your ability to bond with each one
yeah it's pair bonding so so if you
sleep with one guy you're going gonna
compare the next guy to him if you sleep
with 10 guys you compare all 10 if you
sleep with 20 you compare all 20. and
guys hate being compared to other guys
well they hate being but it makes you
more divorced like yeah you're not
likely to be divorced but you're more
likely to leave if you did that because
you're with your husband thinking about
the last like 10 guys that maybe weren't
as good
as the one you married
got down
[Laughter]
are you okay
yeah that's just mad i think that's my
because like like made you thinking it
yeah cause wait but mostly girls okay
girls always go for like a relationship
so cool if they sleep with
more than 10 people
and then they find oh okay more than
five people and they find someone
are they still gonna be
okay cool like
he's not as best as jake like
well
i think
it depends on the girl it absolutely
depends on the girl okay but and it
depends who she marries does she marry a
guy that's better than all the guys she
slept with or does she feel like she's
settled
like like i'll give you an example if
there's a guy like for me and i didn't
realize what i was doing right but if
there's a guy that to me is like like a
nine right and he's talking to me i'm
like why are you talking to me because i
i just immediately think that he wants
like yeah yeah because i'm like you're a
little out of my life
yeah and it's because and i didn't
realize that's an innate like response
to not wanting to be alpha widowed an
alpha widow is basically when you sleep
with a guy that's so high value no one
else can compare
and so every guy so your husband might
pay for it because
you're sleeping with your husband
wishing it was the other guy
and i don't know about you but i've i've
found that there's always girls always
have one x that they like can't get i
can't get over that they can't that it
doesn't matter who they date after
they're always thinking about that last
act and when i was in college i remember
just thinking wow this is so weird like
everyone's got that one and that's
everyone's alpha widow
like i'll give you a story i tell this
story all the time on my show so
there was a girl i went to school with
she was like the girl next door you
never would have known she um
she
slept with a guy or she was dating a guy
for like a month freshman year okay and
they broke up because he was kind of a
player like he cheated on her like in
like a month like that's so soon yeah i
know i know
like you couldn't make it a month
anyways
yeah yeah
so like fast forward four years later
she's dating a new guy this man treats
her like a queen okay he bought her a
house
he bought her yeah she bought her a
house moves her into the house
they're
no they're still together the two this
day i would say he probably wasn't as
like good looking as the guy from
freshman year had like as much of a
smooth talker but like like good
reliable responsible guy bought her a
house moved her in all this stuff we're
at a party okay
and
yeah i'm at a party and she's there and
her the guy that bought her the house
isn't coming but he's gonna get there in
like an hour okay
and i see her she goes into the bathroom
and i'm like why is that like where that
where'd um where'd she go and
and um
and and um
she she comes i see her come out of the
bathroom
with um the guy from freshman year
she was sleeping with him in the back i
don't know how long or what happened i
just i just was like and you never would
have known because she was like the girl
next door and
um yeah she's like still with that the
other guy today
and that so when i think of alpha widow
that's what i think of was she drunk
i don't know probably
yeah no an excuse no
i don't like i wasn't super close with
her like that we were just on the like
we just like we're the same friends
right but i i was like oh my god this
happened so long and this is for like
she's probably hooking up with him the
whole time and so when i think of an
alpha like that's that's the problem
when you get a bigger and bigger body
count is like you're more likely to find
a guy that the next guy can't compete
with especially if you're batting out of
your league
wow
a house are you stupid
with the alpha guy that's tough
he must did he find out how many i
started thinking i don't know i don't i
don't like it it wasn't yo
this was i was a senior so i was just
about to like leave the school so i was
just like
i'm graduating i'm not gonna like left
i'm sorry but men's really shouldn't
lead with their wallets when it comes to
you know in engaging with females they
should not they really should not and
they should yes money is a bonus yeah
it's a nice thing to have it's a nice
thing to flaunt and it's a nice thing to
spend on your on your your partner yeah
but if you're gonna buy a house
and then just
lead with this wallet it was after a
couple years
yeah they were they were together for
like a minute like if he's getting
cheated on but he didn't know i'm
telling you like some guys and i i
maybe you guys would disagree but i
don't think the boyfriends i think it's
very hard for men to tell
if
you're the girl's second choice
because she might you might not be
fighting all the time you might you you
really probably won't ever know
the friends know
yeah yeah they're girlfriends
and they won't tell you either the
family
are you gonna tell the girlfriend if
your friend's cheating yes i
she's let's say she has a boyfriend yeah
yeah she's cheating oh is she she you
know and i know do you tell her
if the guy is she don't know no no i'm
talking about your friend i'm saying if
the cat should i'll tell you yeah i will
yeah yeah of course i think both genders
are loyal to each other in that way
exactly but we're not gonna we're not
gonna snitch if our girl is cheating or
if the guy is cheating that's the thing
so look i've been friends with lj's
since we were like 14 years i was 14
years old he's 16.
like we've been friends for over 10
years right if i if i knew that he had a
wife and he was cheating on her
he i think i could look him in the eye
and say we would probably fight
i think i could look him in the eye and
just genuinely that wasn't the question
would you i
something to say well yeah you might say
it to him but you're not going to go to
his wife well i would probably give him
an ultimatum and say if you aren't going
to tell your wife right but you're
something's going to happen conception
you're not the rule control perhaps
perhaps that's the case he's capping no
i don't think i'm going to hear me out
hit me up i think you're capping on the
sense that if you were in the situation
yes i believe you'd get angry i am more
loyal to my principles than i am my
friend let me finish go on i think you'd
get at him i think as a man of principle
you would speak to him you'd fight him
you'd have that discussion with him yeah
i don't think you would go to the world
personally i don't think it's i don't
think it's right okay i i agree
it's not right for me to directly speak
to her let me out here sorry go go a
bond is between two people they're in a
relationship together there is no third
person yeah the moment you go and
interfere in that right you're playing a
dangerous game i agree i agree here's a
dangerous game you don't know that she
she may already know that he's cheating
yeah but she's happy with the benefits
the moment you come no hit me up the
moment benefits to cheating
so women married or are in relationships
mainly for status
yeah i get that i get that let me finish
they understand
that if they are with a man of high
value they are willing to compromise the
idea of cheating because they understand
that they may not be able to get another
man of that kind of value or status so
they are willing to go through the
[ __ ] as long as it's not
out in the open and people don't know
and yeah he's trying to and and um girls
are more attracted to guys that cheat i
mean why do you think they say men are
trash why do you think they're always
complaining about getting cheated on we
pick them
like
because historically there's biological
roots to everything so historically if a
man could take care of other women that
that meant that um like that meant that
he could take care of us so if we see
that he's taking care of another woman
like then we're attracted to that
it's kind of messed up but how many
girls do you know that get cheated on
and go back